he did a good job or they should have
stuck to the real story Rapunzel is
probably one of the best Disney
Princesses ever but will you like her as
much once you know what really happened
to her stay tuned until the end to know
how her fairy tale ended if you love
Disney princesses as much as we do don't
forget to subscribe and please give this
video a big thumbs up today we are
showing you the disturbing real story
behind Disney's Tangled the beginning
once upon a time there was a man and a
woman who always wished to have a child
but every attempt failed then one day
the woman was looking through the window
and saw a garden filled with the most
beautiful herbs and flowers it belonged
to a witch with great power who was
feared by everyone so no one dared to
enter there but when the woman saw some
Rapunzel in the garden she wanted them
so badly that she became miserably ill
this was when she asked her husband to
get some Rapunzel from the garden or she
would die and he loved her so much that
he decided to do it no matter the cost
this is why he climbed over the high
Hall and the sorceress's garden to steal
the Rapunzel his wife ate it and asked
for more but the the second time you
went into the garden the man got caught
by the witch this is why she asked for
the first child that his wife would
bring to the world and she would take
care of it like a mother the man agreed
and this is how the little Rapunzel was
adopted by the witch but instead of
treating her like her own child she
locked her in a tower with only a little
window when she was 12 years old
whenever she wanted to see her she just
had to ask Rapunzel to let down her hair
and she climbed up the prince Rapunzel
was feeling really lonely in her tower
that was until a prince was riding
through the forest he heard the
beautiful voice of the young woman who
was singing in her Tower unfortunately
he couldn't find any way to climb up the
tower he came back another day and saw
the witch climbing up her hair this is
why he had the idea to pretend that he
was the wish ask Rapunzel to let down
her hair and climbed up the young woman
had never seen a man before and she was
terrified but then he began talking to
her in a friendly Manner and she lost
her fear he immediately asked her if she
would take him as her husband and she
immediately said yes however she didn't
know how to get down this is why she
asked him to bring a strand of silk
every time he would come to the tower
this way she would be able to weave a
ladder and she would climb down when it
would be finished then he would have the
chance to take her on his horse this is
why they made sure that they would be
able to see each other every evening to
make sure that the witch wouldn't see
him during the day however their fairy
tale ended when the young Rapunzel made
one big mistake the pregnancy in the
latest version of the story Rapunzel was
simply dumb enough to ask a really
stupid question out of nowhere she asked
the witch why it was more difficult to
pull her up compared to the young prince
who will be arriving any moment now but
another version of the story is a little
less appropriate for children when you
know that the prince didn't mind
climbing up Rapunzel's hair every night
you probably guessed that his intention
was not only to bring her a strand of
silk after all it would have been easier
to Simply bring a ladder and the couple
would have been able to run away
together but the prince was really
interested in being in her room every
night and you know what this can lead to
the young woman innocently asked the
witch why her waistband was getting
bigger this is when the witch understood
that the young Rapunzel was pregnant the
couple had been having fun before
marriage and the prince never told her
that she could get pregnant from this
this was when the witch understood that
she had been seeing a man during all
this time even though she had tried to
remove her from the world then the witch
decided to punish her and this is not
something that any kid would like to see
the tragedy when she found out that
Rapunzel had been betraying her during
all this time she decided to cut off her
hair then she took the pregnant young
woman Into the Wilderness where she
suffered greatly on the same day the
witch decided to stay in the tower and
tied the cut off hair to the hook at the
top of the tower by the way that means
that Rapunzel would have been able to
escape on her own if she cut her hair
but she also told the witch about her
prince so she was probably not that
smart after spending so many years alone
in a tower anyway the prince asked
Rapunzel to let down her hair and this
was when the witch let down the cutoff
hair to trick him the prince climbed up
the tower and this was when he found the
witch who was waiting for him she told
him you have come for your mistress
darling but that beautiful bird is no
longer sitting in her nest nor is she
singing anymore the cat got her and will
scratch your eyes out as well you have
lost Rapunzel you will never see her
again the prince was overcome with grief
and he threw himself from the tower he
survived but fell into Thorns that poked
out his eyes the end that couldn't be a
fairy tale without a happy ending but
unfortunately it wasn't as good as it
seems the prince had become blind and he
wandered around in the forest eating
nothing but grass and Roots but the most
terrible thing was probably that he lost
the love of his life that was until he
finally found the place where Rapunzel
has been living with the twins she had
given birth to that means that she had
given birth alone in the wilderness even
though she didn't even know what
pregnancy was the prince heard a voice
that sounded familiar he approached it
and this is when Rapunzel finally
recognized him the young woman then
threw her arms around his neck crying
two of her tears fell into his eyes and
the prince wasn't blind anymore this was
when he was able to lead her into his
kingdom where he and his new family were
received with joy in another version of
the story Rapunzel had to live alone in
the desert which makes things worse but
both stories had the same happy ending
the young couple then lived happily ever
after with her two kids we all think
that we know how the story of Cinderella
goes but there's something things we
didn't know and those things can be dark
disturbing and just bizarre stay tuned
to the end to see how the story really
finishes today we are going to tell you
the disturbing real story behind
Cinderella while this Cinderella Story
we all know and love is a nice sweet
tale about good people getting their
rewards and bad people being punished it
hasn't always been so family friendly
one of the more grotesque and gory
versions of the story was the one
written by German storytellers The
Brothers Grimm this is Cinderella just
not as we know it in this version
Cinderella is the daughter of a wealthy
Merchant whose wife dies when he
remarries things take a turn for the
worst however Cinderella's new
stepsisters aren't the ugly sisters who
we are used to they are actually
beautiful but have cruel personalities
and in the brothers Grimm's telling of
the tale the wicked stepmother barely
makes an appearance anyway the sisters
call Cinders Ashen Patel which is German
for Asheville there are other references
too there is no sign of the Fairy
Godmother anywhere in the story here
Cinders has a magical Hazel tree which
she Waters with her tears and grows
above her mother's grave when she wishes
for something by the tree a bird comes
and gives it to her and when the prince
holds his ball the bird gives her
clothes of silver and gold that includes
golden rather than glass slippers but
where it gets really dark is after the
ball the prince finds her Golden Slipper
and fitted on the two stepsisters who
both cut off some of their toes to get
it to fit gross they are then caught
when the Bird Sings the rhyme turn in
peep there's blood within the shoe the
shoe is too small for her the true bride
waits for you very different from the
version of the story that we are all
used to we all know that the story of
Cinderella is old sure but do you know
just how old it is well the very first
example of what would later become the
fairy tale that we all know and love
came out in around the year 7 BC yes yes
it's at least 2 000 years old this
version of the story is about a woman
called rotopus who was a lady of the
course of the pharaoh of Egypt in this
book geographica The Greek geographer
strabo recounts a tale that was told by
the people of ancient Egypt he says that
while rodipus is having a bath an ego
flew down and stole one of her sandals
while her handmaiden's back was turned
the eagle flew all the way to where the
King was and dropped it on his lap the
Pharaoh was so determined to find the
woman who it belonged to that he sent
men to find her when they found rodipus
they brought her to the Monarch who fell
in love with her and made her his queen
of course this is a long way from the
story that we are familiar with but it's
the start of something one of the most
famous parts of the story in Cinderella
is the glass slipper which Cinderella
loses on the way back from the ball when
the handsome prince finds it he becomes
determined to track down its owner when
the shoe fits Cinderella the prince
marries her however there there is a bit
of controversy stemming from what is
believed by some to be a mistranslation
the most famous version of the story is
the one told by French writer Charles
Perrault he is the person who gave us
the idea of a glass slipper being used
by the prince to identify his future
bride however some people believe that
it was really a slipper made of squirrel
fur that is because the French for glass
there and squirrelfur there are very
similar sounding words this has led to a
particularly dark and twisted
interpretation of the story the idea is
that the prince testing out the first
slipper is a reference to the medieval
practice of Dua de Senor that was when a
lord was able to spend the night with
any woman who lived in the area he ruled
over like we said pretty dark stuff
while the story of Cinderella is
something that we all know it has many
influences some of the stories that gave
birth to the tell that we tell today are
pretty disturbing one of them is the
story of fair Brown and trembling this
is a folktale that comes from Ireland
it's about a king Ed karucha who has
three daughters called Fair Brown and
trembling trembling is the most powerful
of the three so the other two hate her
and pick on her sounds pretty familiar
right when the son of the king of the
land of imania is betroth to Fair
trembling is sad because she has no
dress to wear to church however the
woman who looks after the Royal chickens
granted her some magic items which gave
her a dress which meant the prince fell
in love with her trembling lost her shoe
riding from the church which is how the
prince found her however that's where it
gets pretty dark Fair later pushes
trembling into the sea and a whale
swallows her she disguises herself as
her sister but the prince is able to see
through her disguise in the end Fair
gets abandoned in a barrel a long time
ago when children were told stories they
weren't just something to keep them
entertained no they were expected to
teach them lessons about life how to
behave and morality the version of
Cinderella that most modern Italians of
this story are based on was written by
the French author Charles Perrault in
the 17th century all the things that you
would come to expect from the tale are
in there but there is a lesson to be
learned that sort of thing might strike
modern readers as being a little bit
unusual but it was commonplace back in
those days with Cinderella there are two
morals one is that graciousness is more
important than Beauty and the other is
that you can have anything but it could
not bring you any success unless you had
some kind of blessing as we said not
what we'd expect to find at the end of a
story now but we wondered were there any
more disturbing dark and odd things
behind the story of Cinderella if you
know any of them then don't be shy and
tell us in the comments Peter Pan is
arguably one of Disney's best films but
there are some dark things behind the
story that you may not have known stay
tuned to find out why Peter Pan may not
be the good guy you thought he was
changing stories kids aren't really big
fans of change are they that's why
whenever they have to change schools or
a new baby comes into the fan family
there are usually some big issues that
come up but with Disney films kids
usually don't have to worry about change
the films start out the same way every
time but Peter Pan wasn't always so
reliable in fact the film actually
started out as a play then it was turned
into a novel in 1911 called Peter and
Wendy the play first opened in London in
1904. the weird thing about the story
though was that it was always changing
its creator J.M Berry was always
updating it the script changed every
year the version of the story that we've
all seen is the one from the late 1950s
early 1960s can you imagine if Disney
movies changed like that part of the
appeal of them is that you can watch
them when you're young and then come
back when you're older and still get the
same joy and excitement out of the
storyline that you had when you were a
kid if the story changed every year we
wouldn't feel nearly the same amount of
joy that we do now the movies would
never be Classics because Classics don't
change fairy dust you'd never think of
Peter Pan as being a movie that is not
safe for kids to watch the whole object
of the movie is to be a kid forever so
of course course the movie has to be
okay for kids to watch unfortunately
that wasn't always true in fact the
original story of Peter Pan was actually
a bit of a health hazard for children
don't know what we're talking about okay
let's break it down so in the original
versions of the story Peter Pan and the
lost boys could fly on their own this
caused kids who knew the story to try
their own hand at flying there were
reports popping up everywhere of kids
jumping from their beds and trying to
fly of course all these kids soon
learned that they could not fly but not
before they were left with injuries to
combat this JM Berry added fairy dust to
the story and the newer versions of the
tale fairy dust is a necessary component
of flying this made the story much safer
for kids to watch since no kids had
their own little fairy or fairy dust
lying around there were way fewer
injuries after this element was added to
the story The Lost Boys when watching
the film you probably thought how great
it would be to be a Lost Boy to never
have to grow up to stay young and have
fun forever but that Eternal
youthfulness may not have been all that
it seemed in fact there is one line in
the story that people tend to just skip
over but this one line shows what might
be a horrible horrible truth going on
behind the scenes the line in the story
says the boys on the island vary of
course in numbers according as they get
hurt and so on and when they seem to be
growing up which is against the rules
Peter thins them out but at this time
there were six of them counting the
twins as two did you hear that when they
start to age Peter thins them out as in
Peter gets rid of them some users on
Reddit have suggested that the way Peter
gets rid of the Lost Boys is by dropping
them over crocodile infested waters
which is pretty morbid and not really
something we want to spend too much time
dwelling on we just can't believe that
Peter Pan may be a murderer but it is
right there in the line of the story of
course Disney didn't include that in the
film hating adults okay so we all know
that Peter Pan was obsessed with staying
young forever which in itself is a
little creepy he probably should have
been seeing a therapist to work out his
issues of never wanting to age anyway
Peter's fear and disdain of growing
older may have caused him to actually
hate adults and we don't mean in the
normal I don't like adults because they
have too many rules away we mean like
really hate them there is a line in the
story that reads as soon as he got
inside his tree he breathed
intentionally quick short breaths at the
rate of about five to a second he did
this because there is a saying in the
neverland that every time you breathe a
grown-up dies and Peter was killing them
off vindictively as fast as possible see
Peter was kind of evil even if you don't
like adults you shouldn't be out to get
rid of them all what kind of horrible
person does that Peter apparently we
definitely see why Disney left this part
of the story out we can't imagine that
parents would have allowed their
children to watch the film if that part
had been included stealing boys the
author of the Peter Pan story may have
actually been a much darker version of
Peter Pan in real life why because
apparently he stole his own crew of Lost
Boys basically what J.M Berry did was
manipulate his way into the lives of two
people named Sylvia and Arthur Llewellyn
Davies the Davies had three children
George Jack and Peter throughout the
lives of the kids JM spent lots of money
on gifts for the family and would spend
lots of time playing with the boys
having fun in the park and making up
stories later Arthur and Sylvia both
died of cancer within a three-year time
span of each other when this happened
Barry took guardianship of the boys the
real kicker is that he forged Sylvia's
will so that he could take custody of
the kids none of the children's actual
relatives ever objected to him taking
the children years later once Peter had
grown up he said that the whole thing
with Barry taking custody of him and his
brothers was the most pathetic and
ludicrous thing that someone could have
done either this is an extremely sad
tale or a very creepy one perhaps JM
really did want the best for the kids
but forging a will and lying is not the
way to go about it relationship to
Michael okay we may have to take back
what we said about JM maybe wanting what
was best for the boys because when you
look deeper into the story the whole
cool thing just gets creepier and
creepier JM really loved taking pictures
of two of the boys Michael and George
sometimes they would be wearing costumes
that he made and sometimes they would be
wearing no clothes at all if a grown man
stole children and then was always
taking pictures of them today that would
have raised several Flags but for some
reason no one really seemed to be
concerned he even wrote about his weird
relationship with the boys in this book
The Little White Bird even though the
book described him doing some weird
things it was really popular when it was
published to make matters worse in June
of 1908 JM wrote a letter to Michael for
his eighth birthday that was so creepy
it gives us chills it said I wish I
could be with you and your candles you
can look on me as one of your candles
the one that burns badly dear Michael I
am very fond of you but don't tell
anybody
um gross never loving J.M Berry did get
married maybe you're thinking that after
his marriage he the boys and his wife
were one big happy family that isn't the
case at all in fact JM may have never
even loved his wife at all all his wife
Mary Ansel once wrote Love in its
fullest sense could never be felt by him
or experienced isn't that horrible can
you imagine being married to a man who
could never feel love I wonder what made
her marry him in the first place it is
also wildly believed that JM was unable
to have children which may have been
part of why he felt he needed to steal
some eventually Mary grew tired of being
unloved by her husband and sought
affection somewhere else she ended up
having an affair with one of her
husband's friends which led to their
divorce Disney doesn't tell you this
morbid backstory about the creator of
their beloved film there have been
movies about J.M Berry and most of this
stuff is left out he is painted as quite
a kind man and not at all someone who is
unable to love as his former wife Mary
thought everyone left okay this is the
last one about J.M Berry we just had to
point this out if you're on the fence
about the character of the creator of
the play consider this everyone left him
when George and Peter were old enough
they both volunteered to serve in World
War One many said that this was the
boy's way of getting away from JM sadly
George passed away in the war while he
was in Belgium he was only 21 when
Michael was 21 he passed away as well
but in this case he took his own life he
drowned himself in the River Thames
Peter the last surviving adoptive son of
JM also took his own life he passed away
at 63 when he stepped in front of a
train before he passed away he destroyed
most of the letters that his adopted
father had written to him and his
brothers he said that the letters were
simply too much taking all of these
things into account you can see that the
real story behind Peter Pan is really
tragic that's probably why Disney tried
to sweep it under the rug who would
allow their children to watch a movie
created by such a strange and possibly
horrible man the original story in the
original story of Peter Pan he was only
a week old baby when he left home and he
never aged past that in the story Peter
thought that his mother would always
love him and always would leave a window
open for him to return because he wasn't
worried about losing his mother's
affection he's been all of his time
playing with the fairies and the birds
and never worried about going back comb
the problem is that while Peter is away
time is still clicking forward when he
finally does decide to go back home he's
too late his mother has barred the
window so that he can no longer enter to
make matters worse she has a new baby
Peter then believes that his mother's
love was not unconditional as he once
thought and he'd been replaced when you
view the story like this it's quite sad
no one wants to believe that their
mother could just get over them and move
on no one wants to believe that if they
play outside for just a bit too long
that maybe when they come back their
mother will have a new baby maybe that's
why Disney added all those Frills and
feel-good moments to the story so that
people could come away from the movie
feeling good and not depressed Peter Pan
is the villain in both the book and the
play Peter Pan has no problem with
murdering people he does so to the
Pirates pretty easily and then as we
mentioned earlier he may have also been
doing the same to the lost boys who got
too old in the book he also Alters the
bodies of the lost boys so they can all
fit through the tree holes to get to
their underground dwellings how he
Alters their bodies isn't really
specified but we can only think that
he's probably cutting off things or
breaking things so they can fit into
smaller places another thing that makes
him a villain is that he can't tell the
difference between what's real and
what's fake sometimes he gives the last
boys pretend meals and then won't
believe them when they say they're still
hungry in addition to this The Lost Boys
are always in serious danger in the play
and the book but instead of being
concerned for them Peter usually finds
the danger entertaining he always saves
the boys but he doesn't save them
because he loves them he does it so that
he can have a chance to save them again
and show off how clever he is isn't that
just a little bit irritating we all know
and love the Disney classic Pocahontas
but the truth behind the story is
actually a lot more messed up than
anyone ever thought stay tuned to find
out why John Smith and Pocahontas may
have never actually been in love the
film
was it just us or was Pocahontas one of
your favorite Disney Princesses too she
was a total boss whereas most princesses
are kind of Meek and gentle and do
whatever their fathers tell them in the
film Pocahontas was her own person she
did what she wanted and she never took
no for an answer okay if you aren't
familiar with the film first of all what
have you been doing with your life but
we'll be kind and back up a little bit
so the Disney film centers around
Pocahontas who is the daughter of the
chief of the palatin tribe at the
beginning of the movie our favorite
heroine learns that her father wants to
marry her off to kokum who seems nice
and is super hot but Pocahontas just
doesn't love him during all of this time
the British settlers come to
Pocahontas's land John Smith one of the
settlers is less interested in the gold
that his crew came to find and more
interested about actually exploring the
new world while he is exploring he meets
and falls in love with Pocahontas but
their love affair is pretty doomed
because Jon tells his leader that there
is no no gold in the land and instead of
backing off the leader declares that
they will wipe out all of the natives
seems reasonable right in the midst of
all this secret romance and battling
Thomas one of John's friends ends up
taking kokom's life later John is taken
as captive but instead of letting him be
hurt Pocahontas throws herself in front
of Jon and begs her father to save him
and not to start a war Jon is spared but
does end up getting the gunshot wound
and has to travel back to England for
treatment but before they part
Pocahontas promises Jon that he will
always be in her heart so cute right
well it's all a bunch of Make-Believe
Pocahontas is the first Disney movie
that was created about a real life
person except Disney didn't actually
include many of the real details
the real story
here's what really happened apparently
Pocahontas's mother died giving birth to
her her birth name was actually
Metallica which means flower between two
streams and was probably given to her
because she was born between the rivers
of the mataponi and the pamanki after
her mother died Pocahontas's father was
really sad and Pocahontas became his
favorite child because she looked so
much like her mother she was raised by
her aunts and other women in their tribe
during that time it was customary for
the Paramount Chief to have other wives
so Pocahontas's dad had a few other
wives in other Villages so the family
wasn't just Pocahontas and her dad like
the movie made it seem here's where the
story starts to get creepy according to
her tribe history Pocahontas was only
about 10 years old when John Smith and
the colonists arrived in 1607. John
Smith was around 27. so if they did have
something going on it would have been
absolutely disgusting luckily they were
actually never married or even involved
with one another the children of
Pocahontas conscious tribe were all
watched very carefully and because she
was a princess of sorts she was probably
watched even more closely and provided
with cultural training that the other
children did not get on the other side
in the movie we saw John Smith as this
guest guy who saw all men as equal and
was both equally kind and hot in real
life the native people stayed away from
him because he was known to go into
people's Villages and put guns to their
heads and demand food and other supplies
in the winter John Smith met with the
powatin Warriors and ended up being
captured by the chief's brother luckily
for John the powhatans agreed with the
English on one thing they both feared
being attacked by the Spanish so they
formed an alliance after a while the
tribe began to like John and offered him
a role as a leader and gave him a better
area to live in after many years passed
John said that Pocahontas saved his life
during the four day process where he was
initiated into a leadership position
with the tribe but according to written
accounts from Pocahontas's tribe that
could have never happened this is for a
few reasons first the tribe wouldn't
have been trying to hurt him if he was
receiving such a big honor second
children weren't allowed in any of the
ritual ceremonies so Pocahontas wouldn't
have been allowed to be in attendance so
though the movie showed Pocahontas
selflessly throwing herself in front of
John Smith that never happened in real
life Pocahontas also never actually
defied her dad to bring food to John
Smith and his crew in Jamestown why not
well because Jamestown was 12 miles from
where Pocahontas lived there's no way a
10 year old girl would have traveled
that far alone especially not a Chief's
daughter if she did somehow manage to
escape her father and her people to head
to Jamestown she would have had to cross
several bodies of water that would have
required using one of the 400 pound
canoes that her tribe had there was no
way she could have lifted one of those
canoes Into the Water by herself so
Pocahontas actually didn't have much at
all to do with John Smith when she was
15 or 16 she actually did marry Coco one
had a child with him and moved to his
village soon a colonist named Samuel
Argyle went to look for Pocahontas in
order to capture her he demanded that
the tribe give her up or suffer an
attack she was forced to leave her child
in the village and go with Samuel though
she went as she was told kokom was still
attacked after she left later Pocahontas
married Englishman John Ralph and
converted to Christianity some say that
she married him for love but she was
never allowed to see her family again so
it doesn't sound like the relationship
was very mutually beneficial John Ralph
is mentioned in the second Pocahontas
film and she does go on to marry him in
the movie but Disney conveniently leaves
out the kidnapping and how the two ended
up meeting probably because no one would
be able to sleep through the night after
hearing the real story we all love The
Lion King but do you know that it was
actually based on a real story and it
wasn't just one stay tuned to hear more
about the strange biblical story that
was one of the Lion King's main
Inspirations Hamlet
did you know that the Lion King was
actually a loose adaptation of
Shakespeare's Hamlet the story share a
lot of similarities and if you take away
the adorable animals it's actually
pretty disturbing it's hard to believe
such a heartwarming Disney movie could
share the same story as one of
Shakespeare's longest plays to make
things worse the story of Hamlet was
actually based on a true story so keep
that in mind when you watch The Lion
King stay tuned to hear a summary of
Hamlet and some of the similarities this
disturbing story shared with one of our
favorite Disney movies we'll also show
you another weird story that was an
inspiration for a lot of Lion King
moments the real story Hamlet is all
about the prince of Denmark the
depressed and bitter son of the late
King Hamlet just like Simba the prince
of Denmark was an only child without any
other siblings so all focus is on him
throughout the play Hamlet's Story
begins when we get to meet his uncle
Claudius who has already become a king
it's implied that there's a chance this
was done by intentionally ending his
brother's life sounds familiar earlier
yes but we bet it's also pretty
disturbing when there's actual people
involved right but let's continue Hamlet
also has a friend from college called
Horatio who helps him on several
occasions throughout the story he also
ends up falling out with two University
friends after it's revealed they're just
spies who are actually working for
Claudius things get even more
complicated in the early stages of the
story Claudius marries Hamlet's mother
and becomes his own enemy stepfather
when Hamlet hears the details of his
father's murder from a ghost who claims
to be his father's Spirit he decides to
take revenge to make things even worse
Claudius is not the only person young
Hamlet has to worry about when his
father was still alive he won the battle
for a disputed piece of land and ended
up killing king Ford and Bros the King's
son now also wants to avenge the death
and the land that once was owned by his
father the story of Hamlet takes an even
darker turn in the third act when
Hamlet's Revenge plan to kill Claudius
goes wrong instead he ends up ending the
life of of Polonius who was revealed to
be claudius's spy to make things even
more Twisted Polonius has a daughter
Ophelia who's madly in love with Hamlet
but she also ends up not surviving the
play polonius's son is desperate to
avenge his father's accidental death and
ultimately achieve this in the Final Act
of this dark story the long story is
full of mysteries and dark twists that
are full of symbolism and disturbing
imagery in fact one of the most frequent
symbols refers to flowers as every
flower mentioned in the story has a
completely different meaning that
defines the character it's intended for
but it seems like Hamlet is also full of
various characters dying because of
Revenge or accident which seems to also
be one of the main themes in the play so
now you know the brief summary of what
Hamlet's all about let's talk about the
actual similarities to The Lion King
similarities
as we mentioned before both Hamlet and
Simba were princes without any brothers
or sisters they both also feature a
crazy uncle that's jealous of their
father's success and wants to take the
crown away from them both characters
also have a single love interest of
course both of their fathers are also
murdered while King Hamlet's death isn't
quite clear as the only details of the
ACT come from a ghost we all know far
too well what happened to King Mufasa
another interesting detail is that both
fathers reappear as ghosts Mufasa
appears to Simba in The Stars and King
Hamlet's an actual ghost both characters
are also sent to Exile Simba grows up
with Timon and Pumbaa while Hamlet
travels to England and even survives an
attack by Pirates both stories are also
heavily marked by the tone of Revenge
although that might be less obvious in
The Lion King but Simba does take
revenge and we all know hyenas end up
taking care of Scar Claudius on the
other hand is killed with a sword and
poisoned wine both stories also have a
highlighted internal struggle that
drives the main characters to their
ultimate acts in The Lion King we see
Simba struggle with the decision to
become a king as he's too ashamed of his
past and childhood mistakes on the other
hand Hamlet has to decide whether or not
he wants to take Revenge by ending
another person's life
Joseph
but it's not just Hamlet The Lion King
also shares a few similarities with the
biblical story of Joseph and the writers
admitted they took inspiration from the
old testament's Book of Genesis the
story focuses on Joseph the
over-ambitious son of Jacob Jacob had 10
other children who were all aware that
Joseph was the favorite they wanted
revenge and sold Joseph to slave Traders
while telling their father that his son
was killed by wild animals after a long
journey with plenty of moments in
between Joseph eventually ends up in a
position of power and allows him to
punish his brothers and becomes reunited
with his father he also has the power
over the land and makes sure his family
is well off for the rest of their time
while the story of Hamlet is definitely
the one that shares more characteristics
and similarities to the one and only
Lion King the Disney movie was actually
inspired by plenty of biblical stories
like this one and to be completely
honest with you they're all kind of
disturbing when you realize these are
human characters and not adorable
animals and lions that are just learning
how to Roar Plus without a funky musical
number the whole situation is really
dark especially for a story that's meant
to be for kids it's hard to believe
these creepy stories were actually the
base for one of Disney's most iconic
movies isn't it we all watched the
Disney movie The Little Mermaids but
only a few of us know what really
happened to Ariel in the original tale
and this is not a fairy tale story for
kids make sure you watch this video
Until the End to know if the mermaid
lives happily ever after or not if you
love The Little Mermaid as much as we do
don't forget to subscribe and please
give this video a big thumbs up today we
are showing you the messed up origins of
The Little Mermaid here's what Hans
Christian Anderson wrote in 1836 in a
tale called The Little Mermaid once
again The Little Mermaid was one of the
King's Daughters and the most beautiful
of them but this time everyone including
her sisters was fascinated by the human
world and what she loved more was a
Marvel Statue of a handsome man her
grandmother told her everything about
the human world and unlike Scuttle she
was actually really wise she told The
Little Mermaid about the day when she
was going to turn 15 and have the right
to rise up out of the sea sit on the
rocks in the Moonlight and see what is
happening on the land The Little Mermaid
who was the youngest daughter in her
family waited several years for that day
her sisters kept talking about what they
saw and the youngest couldn't wait for
the day when she was going to see it too
at first they were amazed but after
visiting this place too often they
became indifferent and didn't care
anymore when the moment she had been
waiting for finally came The Little
Mermaid Rose to the surface of the sea
this is when she saw a boat came closer
to it and noticed a really handsome
prince it was love at first sight but
then a storm came her man fell in the
water and she had to save him as she lay
on the shore she kissed his forehead and
admired the man who looked just like the
Marvel Statue that she used to love she
waited until someone came to to help him
and then left The Little Mermaid
couldn't forget this man and she spent
many nights in the water near his Palace
to watch The Young Prince unlike her
sisters she kept loving this new world
more every time she learned more about
him every day and even heard the
fishermen talking about how great he was
The Little Mermaid wished that she could
be part of his world however she
realized that they were actually really
different in this tale humans could die
while mermaids could live up to 300
years but humans also had a soul that
lives forever while sea creatures just
ceased to exist when they died this was
one of the main reasons why the Little
Mermaid wanted to become a real woman
her grandmother tried to convince her
that mermaids live to be much happier
and much better than humans but the
young girl didn't mind she could die for
her prince if it meant being happy as
stars in the sky forever but her
grandmother told her that the only way
she could have an immortal Soul was if
the man fell in love with her they ever
got married his soul would Glide in her
body and they would be United this is
why while everyone was at the ball she
decided that she would do anything it
would take to meet her prince her
grandmother told her that a fishtail was
beautiful under the sea but looked
disgusting on Earth and this is why she
had to find a way to have legs she went
to see the Sorceress and even the sea
witch said that she was stupid but there
was something she could do for her The
Little Mermaid could drink a drought
that would make her tail disappear and
turn into legs that would make her the
prettiest little human being they ever
saw but this transformation will feel as
if a sword was passing through her and
every step she takes would feel like she
was treading upon sharp knives if she
could bear with this the Sorceress would
help her and the Little Mermaid was so
desperate that she said yes the sea
witch had to warn her that once she
became human she will never see the ones
that she loves ever again and only
become foam on the crest of the Waves it
wasn't enough to stop the young girl but
then the Sorceress said that she had to
pay the prince in exchange for a pair of
legs she had to give away her voice the
mermaid said yes one last time and the
Sorceress cut off her tongue before
preparing the drought The Little Mermaid
didn't even take the time to say goodbye
to those she loved as she felt too dumb
after making that choice when she rose
up through the dark blue Waters to go on
the shore and drink the magic drought
she felt like a two-edged sword went
through her delicate body and fell just
like she was dead as she discovered from
the sharp pain a prince Stood Beside her
he took her to his Palace but every step
she took felt as if treading upon the
points of needles or sharp knives but
she mostly felt dumb as she couldn't
speak when this handsome man tried to
talk to her she was jealous when she
heard a beautiful slave singing her
voice was so beautiful that the prince
was only looking at her but the Little
Mermaid stole the show when she finally
had the chance to dance with the prince
even the though she was suffering during
all this time she spent more and more
time with her lover kissing and cuddling
but she kept smiling while she couldn't
stop thinking about the pain as the day
passed she was more in love with the
prince but he loved the silent girl only
as he would love a child and not as his
future wife he even called her his dumb
child the prince needed to find a
beautiful princess to marry but he only
had one on his mind he kept thinking
about the woman who saved his life and
the Little Mermaid couldn't tell him
that it was her the prince finally met a
woman who was so beautiful that he
thought that she was the one who saved
him and told the little mermaid that he
was finally happy but the young girl was
heartbroken and it hurt more than her
legs his wedding was going to bring her
to death she held up the bride's train
and danced all night no matter how
painful it was as it was the last night
that she would spend with her prince as
she looked at the Sea The Little Mermaid
saw her sister they had heard about this
tragedy and gave their hair air to the
witch in exchange for a knife if the
young girl plunged it in the heart of
the prince before the sun rises she
would become a mermaid again and have
the chance to be with her family again
but she couldn't do it The Little
Mermaid threw away the knife and threw
herself into the sea where her body
dissolved into foam but she didn't die
she became one of the daughters of the
air by her good deeds she had earned an
immortal Soul she would be flying around
the world in the air until after 300
years she should float into the kingdom
of heaven and this is how the Little
Mermaid had the chance to live her
happily ever after in peace away from
Pain the Disney movie Aladdin is full of
colorful and funny characters singing
catchy songs as they fly around on a
Magic Carpet it's a high-flying tale of
romance magic and Adventure but the real
story is actually pretty messed up the
original author before we dive into the
actual story of Aladdin which is part of
a Saga called Arabian nights or 1001
Nights we have to talk about the woman
who created the stories according to the
Atlantic Arabian Knights is a set of
folk tales that was passed down orally
until the 9th century and then compiled
into a bunch of different written
versions and translations each
translator put their own spin on these
stories depending on their perspective
and the times they were living in but
the truth about the original creation on
these stories is pretty messed up so a
long time ago a psycho-persian king had
a crazy reputation for slaying his new
Brides after their wedding night and
finding a new wife in the morning there
was a clever chick by the name of
shaharazad who knew about the king's
reputation she was forced to marry this
deranged lunatic but she had a little
trick up her sleeve every night before
he went to sleep she would tell the king
a story and end it with a cliffhanger to
keep him in suspense this kept the king
hooked while ensuring she was live
another night because he wanted to find
out how the story ended this girl
basically invented the Cliffhanger in
order to save her own skin the result
was a series of folktales that have been
handed down over the years translated
into a bunch of different languages and
eventually became a Disney movie that we
all loved shaharazad probably would have
loved Robin Williams portrayal of the
genie a common theme in these stories is
the cleverness of women to overcome
oppression acclaims Lebanese author
Hanan al-shek who retold stories of
Arabian Nights had a very interesting
take on this series she said she
believes shaharazad's power over the
king does not stop with her ability to
keep herself Alive by entertaining him
ultimately she exerts far more power
over him than that the author says each
story was a plea for reason and mercy
through all these stories she is trying
to influence the king and maybe even
brainwash him these stories Hanan
al-shek believes slowly taught the king
to give up his evil Tendencies and
hatred of women in her stories
shaharazad mirrors her own predicament
all of her characters are pleading for
life in their own way she cleverly
disguised these stories making the
characters and topics slightly different
but the author pointed out that the main
point of these stories is that you cease
to be a human being if you steep
yourself in brutality and evil it's
important to note that the story of
Aladdin was not added to the collection
of Arabian nights until much later by a
French translator named Antoine's
galland still the story of Aladdin
suddenly becomes much more intriguing
when you think about a woman making it
up on the spot for a Mad King in order
to save her own life
the origin
many people know that Aladdin was
originally set in China because of the
storyteller's Persian Roots Hollywood
set the story in the Middle East with
films like the thief of Baghdad from
1924 and 1940. and of course Disney's
Aladdin but actually the character
Aladdin was Chinese and originally he
wasn't a crafty orphan either the first
version depicted him as a lazy dude who
lived at home with his mom that's far
less appealing right no wonder they
changed the part the Disney film was
originally to be set in Baghdad but the
US was attacking Baghdad in the first
Gulf War while the film was in
production so Disney decided to change
the setting to the fictional city of
Agrabah probably a good idea on their
part
racism
there are a lot of racial stereotypes in
Disney's animated version of Aladdin but
did you know that they actually had to
change the lyrics to the opening song
because it was considered super racist
Arab American activists protested and
caused Disney to change the lyrics after
the film had already been released which
is unprecedented we'll get to those
lyrics in a minute the song wasn't the
only thing the Arab Community had a
problem with according to Don bustany
the president of the Los Angeles chapter
of the American Arab anti-discrimination
committee there Still Remains The Very
sleazy burlesque character in The
prologue and the scene where a merchant
is going to cut off the hands of
Princess Jasmine because she took an
apple from his stand to give to a hungry
child bustany said what's even worse is
that the supporting characters are all
depicted as nasty mean people while the
Aladdin character Jasmine and her father
speak with no accent standard
Americanized English all the bad guys
speak in Foreign Accents the lesson is
that anyone with a foreign accent is bad
he called it horrendous racism now back
to those song lyrics part of the
original lyrics in the opening number of
Aladdin saying about a far away place
where the camels roam where they cut off
your ear if they don't like your face
then the lyrics say it's barbaric but
hey it's home yikes that's pretty dicey
for a Disney cartoon after angry
protests and criticism from the Arab
Community Disney changed the lyrics to
have the characters sing about a Faraway
place where it's flat and immense and
the heat is intense they left the part
where they say it's barbaric Disney made
the change after several meetings with
the Arab American anti-discrimination
Committee Disney distribution President
Dick cook said it was something they did
because they wanted to do it he said in
no way would they ever do anything that
would be insensitive to anyone so on
reflection they changed it still the
Arab American anti-discrimination
Committee was not completely happy with
the change and requested to have the
word barbaric removed from the song as
well but Disney refused saying that the
word barbaric referred to the land and
the Heat and not to the people what do
you think should they have changed the
word barbaric it appears we still have a
long way to go with learning how to be
kind inclusive and tolerant but as
Aladdin has taught us it's never too
late to apologize and make things right
let's hope Disney has learned from this
and applies it to the Remake they have
an opportunity to create a film from a
story that was born from horrible
oppression and perhaps turn it into a
Triumph of the human Spirit an inclusive
celebration of culture and a few more
catchy tunes that have us tapping our
toes rather than shaking our heads A
Tale As Old As Time sounds romantic but
if it hadn't been changed to the Disney
movie we know and love there's a good
chance you might not be as much of a
Beauty and the Beast fan keep watching
to find out how Belle was meant to ease
the fear of an arranged marriage the
recent Beauty and the Beast live-action
movie features one of Hollywood's most
beloved feminists Emma Watson it's
difficult not to look for elements of
equality in a movie that continues to be
such a big part of our childhood however
like any narrative it's important to
examine where the story comes from if
anything unveiling the story's darker
past might even add to our current
appreciation of the film and the
corresponding adjustments and tweaks the
story has undergone throughout its life
not always so strong and independent
there are a lot of misconceptions when
it comes to our interpretations of the
Love Story between Belle and the Beast
for example many fans perceive Val's
ability to make her own decisions as a
sign of her independence like when she
courageously sets out to save her father
this is impressive for a Disney princess
as she strives to defy the patriarchy
that tries to limit her usefulness to
solely her good looks some have gone as
far as viewing Belle as a feminist
character though this may be true for
our perspective in our current social
climate the tale originated as part of
the oral storytelling tradition this
would have been decades prior to any
social or Civil Rights Movement making
it impossible for Belle to be a feminist
in her cultural and historical context
where does the story come from
looking at where the story of Beauty and
the Beast originated is very helpful in
understanding how far our interpretation
of bell has come a professor of folklore
and mythology Marie Tater explained how
this contextual change happened Tater
divulged in a grammar interview that the
story of Beauty and the Beast has
existed among communities for longer
than we can track the story we know and
love was first published in print by
French author Madame Gabrielle Suzanne
de vinov in this version Bell is a good
fairy and the descendant of a king this
tale was based on the real story of
Petrus gonzalves and his bride Catherine
Tetris was afflicted by a condition
called hypertrichnosis which caused
excessive hair growth all over his body
he was initially adopted by the French
royal family for their Amusement Petrus
would go on to marry Catherine and they
became a celebrity couple so using them
as inspiration for a printed version of
the existing oral tell makes sense after
all people want to read about things
they have experience with however it was
a friend author Jean-Marie Le Prince de
Beaumont who wrote a second print
version of the fairy tale beaumont's
version was meant to serve as a lesson
for girls ranging from ages as young as
5 to 13. her goal was not to empower
young women and Inspire them to make
their own decisions quite the opposite
Beauty and the Beast was meant to prove
to Young 18th century readers that
arranged marriages aren't as bad as they
may seem for a girl a potential husband
who was older and much hairier would not
be so unlike the Beast Belle eventually
Falls for by the time it was Rewritten
by Beaumont Belle was no longer royalty
but instead the daughter of an inventor
the purpose of this was to ensure that
the story would be relatable to a French
population that was becoming
increasingly frustrated by the growth of
an aristocratic class the story was then
interpreted into the version we know
best by English author named Andrew Lang
this version was the most popular as it
was translated into several languages
and served as the inspiration for movies
and songs
the Disney version
finally in the most recent live-action
film director Bill Condon added another
modification in this version Bell is an
inventor who creates a washing machine
to provide her with more time for
reading the nature of the invention has
also been criticized as Reliant too
heavily on gender roles we can use this
as a true Testament of how far audiences
have come the Disney animated and
live-action narrative suggests that Bell
makes an independent decision to save
her father and sacrifices her own
freedom in exchange the Beast depicted
as angry and violent eventually succumbs
to Belle's intelligence and kindness and
they find the love that transcends
appearance this is not the case in the
original story instead Bell is sent to
live with the Beast who is more
attractive and offers her any luxury she
desires by the end of the story she
accepts her situation and falls in love
with the creature she's been destined to
marry this would not have been too
unlike young girls who were forced to
marry older men another theory presented
by Tater is that the bee serves as a
metaphor for fear itself following this
Logic the Beast is a representation of
Belle's fears once she confronts these
fears and feels at peace with them she
is able to see the Beast for who he is
as her judgment is no longer clouded by
her concerns essentially through the
scary image of the Beast the audience is
supposed to learn that the worst part of
being held captive against your will is
your fear once you move past that you
will see that life isn't as bad as it
seems Disney found a way to flip this on
its head making sure that the beast's
insecurities were the reason for his
harsh attitude towards the rest of
society that had exiled him the takeaway
on one hand Disney is advocating for a
feminist rendition of Beauty and the
Beast on the other hand we may continue
to find fault in the problematic power
dynamics that Prevail in all retellings
of the story nevertheless the movie
continues to bring up important
questions about what it means to be in a
healthy relationship as long as it's
properly contextualized for a young
audience presenting difficult and
uncomfortable narratives from an
outdated literary tradition might cause
us to continue to question the gender
roles we still take for granted
according to Disney Belle's compassion
and intelligence allows beasts to show
himself for who he is instead of Belle
having to accept her situation she helps
the Beast confront his own issues and
become a better version of himself
somehow Disney has successfully turned a
story about female oppression and
arranged marriages into an inspiring
lesson about seeing others for who they
truly are that's it for our video don't
forget to subscribe to the things and
hit that like button for more videos
like this one